le lieu où j'expose la kinta domenica
qui est une fondation qui est une
fondation culturelle draine beaucoup de
touristes il ya beaucoup de gens qui
viennent il sort il ya un très grand une
très très bonne affiche à l'extérieur et
les gens sont déjà attiré par cette
affiche est entre et découvre ma
peinture et il y à des américains vous
avez des canadiens donc ma peinture
attirent énormément et au niveau des
peintres de saint domingue
ils sont très attirés par mon travail
parce qu'ils me connaissent aussi il
faut dire qu'il ya une quinzaine
d'années j'ai eu à saint domingue
le prix de la meilleure exposition de
peintres de peintre à saint domingue la
meilleure exposition étrangères de
pintes racines à saint domingue
est ce ce diplôme avait été m'avait été
délivré par l'association des critiques
d'art de saint domingue
l'expressionniste qui se dégage 2009 est
en fait le résultat de l'ensemble de de
pratique que j'ai depuis quelques années
est effectivement ma base de peinture
c'est le compte de la martinique la
culture de la martinique
les histoires de la martinique que j'ai
essayé et que j'essaye jusqu'à présent
de mettre en image dont tout ce symbole
qu'on rencontre dans le créole
martiniquais que j'essaie depuis
quelques années de mettre en volume de
mettre en forme de mettre en couleur
d'où cette impression de
de symbolisme et d'expressionnisme qui
se dégage de ce travail
ce travail très coloré c'est vrai mais
c'est un travail où il ya beaucoup de
références à la peinture à la culture
plus généralement de la martinique
ce qui me motive à leur première moi je
les dis déjà ma peinture j'essaie de
m'en créer un peu dans la réalité
culturelle de la caraïbe alors haut
niveau en tant que poète martiniquais
s'est pas chose facile parce qu'on a
beaucoup de références au niveau de
l'europe au niveau de la france mais
vivant dans cette aire géographique qui
à la caraïbe
j'ai toujours voulu me référer à cette
histoire à cette culture qui est un peu
à l'image de la culture de la martinique
donc je considère la martinique comme
appartenant à la caraïbe
donc je me dis toujours que je suis un
peintre caraïbes est d'ailleurs le team
de l'exposition qui a en ce moment à la
kinta dominique a et la caraïbe 7
caraïbes qui nous qui nous unit dont qui
unit les peintres de la martinique qui
unit les peintres de cuba si bien que
quand j'expose à saint domingue
on me dit alain vraiment tuer tuer un
pet être vraiment caraïbes et quand
gspot j'expose à cuba on me dit la même
chose
donc si bien j'essaie d'y exporter dans
les autres endroits tels l'europe comme
tu l'as dit partout où j'expose j'essaie
de mettre ce petit grain de sa de sel
caraïbéen et montrer que j'appartiens
que j'appartiens à un grand ensemble qui
est la caraïbe